[Musica]
per alzata di mano chi di voi pensa di
aver scoperto il proprio talento
se vi chiedessi dirmi una cosa nella
quale pensate di essere veramente bravi
probabilmente qualcuno di voi mi direbbe
sa cantare sa ballare sa praticare
qualche tipo di sport e sono sincero io
non penso di essere un talento mi sono
sempre riconosciuto più che altro nella
figura del muratore in qualcuno che il
giorno dopo giorno ha cercato di
costruire qualcosa di sempre più solido
ma come tanti da piccolo avevo la
passione per il calcio e quindi magari
mi sarebbe piaciuto diventare un bravo
calciatore ma i miei genitori avevano
per me un piano molto diverso da era
così giovane e anche ingenuo che mi
convinsero che in tutta la città di roma
non c'era neanche una scuola calcio la
verità era leggermente diversa sono il è
quindi immaginiamo questi grandi prati
verdi come qualcosa che esisteva solo
lontano dalla città o in luoghi remoti
quindi avevo capito la prima regola che
molto spesso la strada per il talento
non è necessariamente quella più vicina
a casa
la verità è che ho altri tre fratelli di
cui una bellissima sorella gemella e
quindi i miei genitori dovevano
semplicemente cercare di conciliare le
esigenze di tutti anche solo per motivi
logistici e di trasporto
quindi pensavano che fosse molto più
opportuno e scrivere sia me che mia
sorella gemella a un corso di ginnastica
artistica che non era proprio la cosa
che avevo in mente
e se ripensa a quegli anni in realtà
furono anni anche molto positivi e
piacevoli perché era l'unico bambino in
un corso di ragazze e quindi ero anche
quello forse più coccolato che la
seconda regola era dunque che la vita è
un continuo compromesso non sempre può
avere subito
che vuoi ma se ripensa a quegli anni
l'esperienza fu piacevole ma allo stesso
tempo ero triste ero triste perché
capivo che quella percorso mi stava
comunque tenendo lontano da quella che
era la mia più grande passione un certo
tipo di sport e al tempo il calcio ma
poi parlando con i miei genitori mi
convinse di iscrivermi ad un corso di
tennis e proprio di fronte scuola quindi
non potevano dirmi di no avevo visto che
c'erano scuola tennis di fronte a scuola
la terza regola bisogna sempre negoziare
e quella racchetta da tennis divenne la
mia migliore amica quindi per tanti anni
abbiamo giocato insieme siamo riusciti
arrivare anche in america a giocare
vicino ad alcuni degli atleti che poi
hanno fatto la storia di questo sport e
quindi sempre in maniera ingenua pensavo
che il mio futuro sarebbe potuto essere
nei campi da gioco mentre in realtà a 18
anni mio padre mi diede un altro
consiglio molto saggio
inizia a rallentare con il tennis e
concentrati sull'università e
l'università per me fu un periodo molto
bello perché mi appassionai subito ai
concetti del marketing e studia i tutti
i libri di un professore professore
filippo ottica che proprio il padre del
marketing e moderno e se non l'avete mai
sentito vi basti pensare un numero il 60
per cento di tutte le persone che nel
mondo studia marketing lo fa su un suo
libro e quegli anni furono sicuramente
positive e rapidamente ho avuto
l'opportunità di andare a lavorare in
due delle più importanti aziende di
marketing al mondo che sono procter and
gamble e unilever però in quegli anni
stava succedendo qualcosa ho visto
arrivare il mondo dei social media 2009
2010 e ho capito che rapidamente
avrebbero cambiato in modo in cui le
aziende comunicano e decisi dunque di
licenziarmi per provare a creare una
piccolissima società specializzata in
social media marketing è una decisione
così importante di rinunciare a un
qualcosa di certo per una visione su
quello che sarebbe successo l'ho presa
con una flessione molto semplice
immaginate di avere su una mano
le vostre competenze vostri talenti
qualcosa che sapete fare molto bene
immaginate di avere su un'altra mano le
competenze che vi vengono richieste nel
vostro lavoro attuale
ora voi siete veramente sicuri che le
due mani combaciano perfettamente o
magari stare sacrificando alcuni dei
vostri talenti perché nel vostro lavoro
quotidiano non non vi servono e non vi
vengono richiesti alla fine la risorsa
veramente più scarsa che tutti noi
abbiamo un
e il tempo quindi se voi capite che
state dedicando tempo a qualcosa di
interessante ma che non fa leva sul
vostro vero talento
dovete avere il coraggio di tagliare le
vele quindi di interrompere qualcosa di
piacevole per cercare di fare un salto
su qualcosa di ancora più piacevole
cercando però di fare veramente
esperienza di tutto quello che avete
imparato in quel percorso che abbiamo
portato fino a lì e ho voluto preparare
per voi qualche esempio di personaggio
famoso che è riuscito a cambiare la
propria vita mi sono immaginato cosa
sarebbe successo se non avesse fatto
questo cambiamento e ho anche scoperto
studiando per voi per questo terre talk
che probabilmente se non avesse cambiato
percorso andrea bocelli oggi sarebbe un
avvocato oppure v di colbert premio
oscar
se non avesse cambiato percorso non solo
avrebbe continuato probabilmente a fare
la truccatrice ma lei faceva la
truccatrice per i defunti per i funerali
qualcosa di veramente particolare che
lei però racconta con grande ironia come
un percorso importante della sua vita e
ho cercato un ultimo esempio ancora più
forte che è quello del santo padre
se il santo padre non avesse cambiato
percorso non avrebbe fatto l'attore come
questa slot e con vin diesel vi potrebbe
far immaginare ma hanno qualcosa in
comune entrambi hanno fatto il
buttafuori il santo padre era il
buttafuori in un locale malfamato di
cordoba fonte wikipedia e quindi mi
piace raccontarvi che se ne deve pensare
come le persone per noi rappresentano un
ambiente una carriera ma realtà la loro
la storia è piena di cambiamenti e c'è
una frase importante che abbiano
espresso detta molto spesso e vi parlo
di un top manager che parlò con un suo
dipendente che con molta sincerità gli
disse la mia carriera va benissimo chi
sono molto grato ma io sento dentro
qualcosa che mi fa venir voglia di
cambiare percorso è il mezzo nissimo
vecchi ok capisco sarebbe una bellissima
idea se tu però non avessi già un lavoro
c'è perché cerchi qualcos'altro
e lui non riuscivo a capire proprio
quale quell'energia che all'interno
questo giovane dipendente decise dunque
di lasciare new york di lasciare wall
street per andare a lavorare
all'inizio come tanti in un garage per
creare quella che poi è diventata amazon
è che tutti tutti conosciamo e ci sono
alcune persone che sono estremamente
fortunate perché capiscono subito qual è
il loro talento forse quelle che prima
hanno alzato la mano e quindi è come se
avessero il vento in poppa quindi vanno
molto più veloce degli altri per
cannocchiale alla direzione se dovessi
pensare a una persona nel mondo dello
sport probabilmente michael phelps che
con la ventitreesima medaglia d'oro che
ha vinto è diventato l'atleta più
titolato nella storia delle olimpiadi ma
è molto più probabile che la maggior
parte di voi e si riconoscano un
concetto diverso recente che anche io ho
scoperto studiando un talk di qualche
anno fa che è il concetto di multi
potenzialità ciascuno di voi magari
dentro a un talento che può esprimere in
tanti campi diversi quindi non è brava
in una sola cosa potrebbe eccellere in
tanti campi diversi e se volessimo
rimanere nel mondo dello sport abbiamo
tantissimi casi
oggi vi presento per esempio è di gran
che è riuscito a vincere la medaglia
d'oro nel pugilato e 12 anni dopo a
vincere la medaglia d'oro nel bob a
quattro due discipline completamente
diverse oppure un'altra atleta canadese
clara hughes che ha vinto sia come
pattinatrice ma anche come ciclista il
caso secondo me più emblematico di tutti
e johnny with new leur che ha vinto
tante medaglie nel nuoto
battendo anche molti record ha vinto
anche nel mondo della pallanuoto ma se
vi chiedessi per cosa vi ricordate
questo è questo personaggio
probabilmente per quello
lui divenne famoso per lo step
successivo in cui fece il ruolo di
tarzan e questo è il suo famoso urlo è
sicuramente un buon esempio di muti e
potenziale
vorrei raccontarvi anche un aneddoto
italiano
quindi c'è un talento italiano una donna
che anni fa ha creato quello che oggi
conosciamo come bacio perugina ma allo
stesso modo
inventò pettinando dei conigli
un modo per utilizzare i loro per i per
creare abbigliamento e poi il suo figlio
e tutti gli eredi diedero vita a quella
che oggi conosciamo come luisa spagnoli
ma in realtà ciò di cui voglio parlarvi
ora non è il talento in senso puro ma a
trovare un modo per capire come
utilizzare il talento per creare
qualcosa di ancora più grande e ancora
piu importante e vi consiglio di
studiare un concetto bellissimo che è il
concetto di ikee gai che riassume bene
ciò che ho iniziato a dirvi in questo
discorso e liti gravi dice cercate di
capire una cosa che sapete fare molto
bene
la prima domanda che vi ho fatto
qualcosa che amate fare quindi è un
piacere farla qualcosa che qualcuno è
disposta a pagarvi per fare e non è per
niente scontato se no diventa solo un
hobby ma soprattutto qualcosa di cui il
mondo ha bisogno
se voi riuscite a trovare un talento che
ricopre tutte e quattro queste aree
avrete trovato il vostro kikai che poi
potremmo tradurre come il senso della
vita
ora molto spesso mi chiedo prima o poi
arriverà una notizia positiva
una notizia che probabilmente cambierà
in positivo proprio il mondo e mi chiedo
ma chi ne sarà all'artefice si avrà
inventato questa nuova tecnologia che
veramente cambierà il mondo e
probabilmente potrebbe essere uno
scienziato che da 20 30 anni studia in
maniera super approfondita una sola
tematica e diventa il più esperto di
tutti ma forse potrebbe anche essere un
giovane ragazzo che nella sua vita ha
fatto tante esperienze magari è un multi
potenziale anche tante passioni e quindi
riesce ad approcciare lo stesso problema
con un approccio completamente diverso
dando
una missione davvero outsider e sono
convinto che la vera innovazione la si
possa avere soprattutto quando c'è
l'incontro di più campi di più
specializzazioni molto spesso
l'innovazione è un puro tema di
allineamento e vi ho presentato adesso
qualche caso di outsider che sono
riusciti a portare tecnologie e
soprattutto approcci diversi in mondi a
loro lontani cosa succede se mettiamo
insieme il mondo della natura con il
mondo della tecnologia
c'è un ragazzo che è riuscito a creare
il primo sistema di sorveglianza delle
foreste semplicemente utilizzando dei
telefonini dismessi che magari avete voi
nei vostri cassetti ea tararli per
riconoscere il rumore delle moto si è
che quando qualcuno in maniera
clandestina sta tagliando un albero
lui è riuscito con un approccio coerente
diverso a trovare una soluzione un
problema che da anni non riusciva essere
risolto oppure se mettiamo insieme il
mondo del mare e delle onde con il mondo
dei droni una tecnologia sempre più
moderna c'è un ragazzo in cina che ha
creato il primo bambino rom e quindi un
bambino che è in grado di salvare una
vita umana
andando a 10 metri al secondo sull'acqua
riuscendo a salvare dunque in maniera
più veloce e soprattutto senza mettere a
rischio la vita di un altro panino
oppure perso ai medici dello zoo in
maryland che sono riusciti a unire la
loro passione per la medicina ma anche
la passione per i lego e sono riusciti a
salvare questa tartaruga in una maniera
molto molto creativa e probabilmente
qualcuno di voi avrà sentito che
esistono delle app per incontri la più
famosa è e kinder e ho scoperto
un'associazione in america incredibile
ti ha creato
progetto per mettere insieme il mondo
desideri incontri con il mondo dei
cuccioli dei cani nei canili e loro
hanno detto ma se le persone cercano
compagnia su queste acque perché non
mettiamo dentro la app dei cuccioli in
maniera tale che al posto di trovare una
ragazza un ragazzo magari proprio
incarna nella tua città che ti dice
perché non li adotti e questo come un
caso di alzate molto molto interessante
è assolutamente replicabile
un ultimo esempio dei ragazzi in brasile
hanno messo insieme il mondo della moda
con il mondo della tecnologia che sono
riusciti a creare il primo cappello che
riesce ad avvertire un camionista se si
sta per addormentare dandoli
accendendoli una luce davanti piuttosto
che facendo vibrare il cappello o
facendo un rumore e salvando molte vite
tutti questi e se gli servono per dirvi
che sono convinto che le idee che voi
potete avere sono direttamente
proporzionali al numero di stimoli che
ricevete e non vi sto dicendo ripara
esperienze estreme e cercare stimoli in
acciaio che con il paracadute ma vi sto
dicendo di avere un approccio in cui la
mente deve essere aperta perché la mente
come un paracadute è veramente funziona
solo se si apre l'anno scorso ho
scoperto una cosa molto interessante
mark zuckerberg fondatore di facebook
quando ha avuto l'idea ha invitato
cinque amici i suoi colleghi
universitaria tar parte nella sua stanza
dicendo se venite questo pomeriggio vi
racconto l'idea dovuto sapete quanti si
sono presentati dei cinque in due quindi
tre di tre persone hanno rinunciato all
opportunità di co fondare facebook
quando ho scoperto questa storia ho
fatto un post sul link di dicendo
va bene lavorare va bene lavorare tanto
ma cercate almeno la sera di staccare e
di passare tempo anche con altre persone
volendo anche con davis conosciuti per
condividere stimoli e informazioni in
questa maniera non ridete posto cervello
e avrete molte più idee quel posto è
diventato virale ha superato le 700 mila
visualizzazioni e qui abbiamo
incominciato a organizzare delle cene di
tutta italia a roma a firenze a milano
nel quale molti si sono incontrati anche
molti sono oggi qui con con noi e sono
felicissimo di essere oggi a bologna
perché per la prima volta dopo la
pandemia e la quarantena
abbiamo ricominciato a organizzare delle
cene proprio ieri abbiamo fatto una cena
con alcuni dei miei studenti e ho
scoperto delle cose incredibili ho
voluto aggiungere una strada al discorso
perché tra di noi c'è antonio che non
solo è quattro volte campione italiano
di scacchi faceva parte anche della
nazionale ma ci ha raccontato come lui
ogni anno insegna 2.000 bambini come
costruire una scacchiera utilizzando
tappi di bottiglia riciclata scatole
della pizza uomo qualunque altro
prodotto che se noi andremmo a buttare e
poi la volevo raccontare perché è molto
probabile che jade così siano genitori o
insegnanti che domani stesso possono
provare a replicare questa iniziativa e
suisse teheran
mi hanno già scritto in tantissimi
dicendo con la voglia deprecata
possibilità di contatto con antonio
l'altro ieri sempre a bologna abbia
fatto una c'era una persona incredibile
alec ross consigliere innovazione di
obama hillary clinton che ha scelto di
vivere un anno a bologna per insegnare
nella posta università e lui ha
accettato l'invito di venire a cena
non c'è una persona così interessante
tra il quale ci ha raccontato gli
aneddoti della casa bianca dello studio
ovale punti come si comporta obama
quando prendere sono importanti credo
sia fondamentale portare al tavolo anche
un giovane talento uno dei ragazzi più
giovani e talentuosi delle mille ricorsi
che possa trarre ispirazione da queste
persone per poi magari portare
innovazione nel nostro paese
tutto questo per dirvi che sono convinto
che solo con questa metodologia molto
aperta senza aspettarsi niente incanto
della singola cena possono capitare cose
magiche e chiudono e ricordare
l'approccio da muratore dove ogni giorno
cercate di fare un piccolo passettino
ma a distanza di dieci anni possono
capitare cose magiche nella mia vita
sono successe cose che mani sarei
aspettato e mi sono ritrovato quindi con
la mia piccola ci sia magari a lavorare
con alcuni degli atleti più importanti
al mondo come tenniste che vedevo da
molto lontano o a lavorare alla gestione
social con il kosice violenti rete di
home non intende di un channel e altri
progetti incredibili addirittura del
famoso professore che studiamo sui libri
di testo
l'anno scorso non ho ancora capito come
vanno trovate a fare una lezione sia in
suite ed è stata un'emozione per me è
incredibile
l'aspetto più ski e surreale è stato
l'aver avuto perché a riconoscere che
offre una scena uno chef preferibile che
è stato il mio complice nel momento
permette più emozionante della mia vita
quando ho chiesto a giulia di sposarmi
aiuterei dunque con
una piccola riflessione cercate di
essere curiosi allenando ed avere una
mente sempre aperta e cercate al vostro
fianco una persona con cui amplificare
rispettivi talenti
io sono molto fortunato l'ho trovata
purtroppo cove della pandemia ha fatto
posticipare al 2021 il nostro progetto
per i matrimoni che era cui tre mesi fa
perché vi chiederei un applauso per e
gioia della sua famiglia per l'altro
grande pazienza che grazie
[Applauso]